[Music]
it's been a crazy week in america let's
find out what happened
as part of the white house's help is
here campaign
vice president harris and second
gentleman doug
emhoff visited denver colorado said
officials in denver
sir is this woman bothering you no she's
my wife you know but not she bothered me
she's the vice president of the united
states she looks so regal does she trust
her
singer beyonce on sunday won her 28th
grammy award wow that's one grammy for
every year it looks like she's been
alive yeah
she looks good yeah
utah lawmakers recently voted to make
smart phones
sold in the state come with pornography
filters
and in case you're wondering this is
what counts as porn in utah
[Laughter]
coronavirus cases at duke university
reportedly
quadrupled last week after fraternity
recruitment events
so just to be safe officials are
encouraging everyone
to pledge yeah
come on yeah
own it work it you did it get it
off the rails before anything has
started it's
incredible though that pledge joke that
pledge joe
i mean yeah come on i'm saying
a british man
a british man recently set a new
guinness world record for
drinking a capri sun pouch in 16.65
seconds
the record for opening a capri sun pouch
is three hours and 21 minutes
it's hard to do why are you failing at
school i couldn't open my juice
you guys i'm so sorry about today i'm so
sorry
the ken doll turned 60 last week and
he sure looks good but most of it is
plastic
who are you telling that to
oh ken looks great for his age yeah
well most of that is plastic i didn't
want ken to hear me
he's sensitive you guys
lip's appreciation day was this week
sorry white people
and finally walmart announced that it
has hired its first
fashion creative director designer
brandon maxwell who has styled
celebrities like lady gaga
so expect big changes in the frozen meat
department
and that was the monologue tarik did you
like the monologue
i did
what's going on here what do you mean
what are you wearing
my costume for the bit what bit
the baggins fourth i'm sorry did you say
back and forth or baggins fourth
because i asked you to come up with a
quick snappy conversation for us to have
after the monologue
a back and forth
but it looks like you heard baggins
fourth which
i can only assume you interpreted as
some sort of lord of the rings themed
fantasy sketch in which you play frodo
baggins while wearing what looks to be
a very expensive movie quality costume
bilbo baggins yeah the rest is pretty
much spot on
are those custom-made hobbit feet
they are and how much was the costume
three weeks budget great so to be clear
there is no back and forth there is not
and what did we learn how to go on an
adventure tarek that
i need to be a better listener and i
learned not to give tarik
access to the budget now friends
we are so close to the end of this
pandemic i know it's tempting to start
doing away with a lot of the safety
measures that have dominated our lives
for the past year but
i just want to take a moment to say
please keep wearing a mask
please keep social distancing and if you
qualify for a vaccine please get one
and to motivate us all to do these
things i'd like to remind you of some of
the good stuff we have to look forward
to when the pandemic is over
in a segment called stuff to look
forward to
[Music]
here's some stuff to look forward to
going to a concert and becoming
temporary best friends with the
strangers next to you
for the duration of the concert as you
all sing at the top of your lungs
but you can't sing at the top of your
lungs if your lungs are filled with
fluids so wear a mask
locking eyes with your best friend at
your other best friend's wedding when
the pastor says
if anyone here has a reason why this
couple shouldn't be married
because y'all know some [ __ ] but that
beautiful moment of friendship may never
happen if you catch coven and die
because you didn't want to wear a mess
to pick up your take out order from tgi
fridays
mediocre apps are not worth it
going back to the office and seeing your
favorite co-worker who gives you the
juicy gossip about your least favorite
co-workers crumbling marriage
but you can't go back to the office if
you're sick at home
stay six feet apart
traveling to a new country where you
immerse yourself in new cultures and
foods for a little bit and then
eventually fall back into your old
everyday habits and end up eating at
mcdonald's in france
but some countries won't even let you in
unless you're vaccinated
so do it so you can eat french mcnuggets
they call them lay mcnuggets
[Laughter]
eating an amazing family meal with loved
ones you haven't seen in over a year
then immediately remembering exactly why
your visits are scarce even when there
isn't a pandemic
but that dinner with loved ones will be
very different if you can't taste any of
the food because your sense of taste has
been ravaged by covid
don't you want to taste your mother's
food
so please continue to be safe and make
good choices because
right now you're the stuff someone is
looking forward to seeing and
seeing that happen for so many people is
exactly the stuff i'm looking forward to
most
this has been stuff to look forward to
now march is women's history month and i
was going to say a little something
about it but
taric asked me if he and james could do
it instead so
here's tarik and james with a special
song for the women
[Music]
and lift us all up when we're feeling
down all
women yeah we're proud to say
without them we would not be standing
here today
it's the women who have made us strong
and we're celebrating with this song
this one's for gail davis who gave me
life
who took me into bed every single night
and also for monica a sister of mine
for teaching little james and for
letting him shine
this once for our friends mom mrs the
king
she taught us about betting and casinos
and things
and also for her daughter her name is
renee who said you're better now i
gamble your money away
oh women yeah we're proud to say
without them we we're not presenting
here today it's
women who make the world go brown they
lift us all
up when we're feeling down
[Music]
this goes out to the girl who drove a
sereno
and wonders about the crazy guys who
owned the casino
she said to make sure we never owe them
a scent or they throw us in the river
which jews are cement
this one is for a lady by the name of
irene
who told us not to bet our life savings
hungry
and also for miranda cause she is a
queen for not laughing when we lost our
life savings on green
this one goes to an angel by the name of
grace
who drove us far away on a high speed
chain
this one is for a lady named jennifer q
she
hit us in the house when the mob came
through
this one goes out to maya she's greater
than great you gotta strike our keys and
lose us
out of state and finally to amber cause
she is a blessing
standing in the corner saying stop
[Music]
confessing
[Music]
i have my own youtube channel now yay be
sure to subscribe for a lot of show
clips and a lot of digital exclusives
and a lot of this
you